from reuters.com Ohio House of
Representatives overrides video V veto
of Bill Banning gender affirming care so
one of the one of the big cultural
issues of course is the issue around
transgender youth uh uh transgender
ideology gender ideology as it pertains
to sports and of course one of the
truths that you have listed is that
there are two genders so many of us were
shocked to see that in Ohio despite the
fact that the house passed this bill
saying no to child sex changes the
governor tried to veto that I'm curious
your position on this if you'd like to
elaborate and break it down yeah I and
it happens to be my home state actually
born and raised and live in Ohio now as
well so I was disappointed but not
shocked as how I would characterize it
based on the governor that we now have
in Ohio actually spoke to the lieutenant
governor I was sort of like what the
heck call who I actually have a good
relationship with and turned out that he
is also against the position that the
governor took and so the governor of
Ohio is is you know he's like the
equivalent of like the chrison news the
Nikki Haley the you know Chris Christies
you could say of the world dwine the
governor of Ohio just falls into that
category I mean there's a there's a
brand of people who put a nice little r
after their name but aren't really
thinking according to clear principles
they're easily captured I think in this
case what my understanding was and I
haven't talked to the governor but I've
talked to a lot of people who are
familiar with the situation is a lot of
people are making good money off of some
of this gender conversion stuff and sold
a myth that somehow this is going to
cause suicide amongst kids and you're
going to have blood on your hands and so
what ended up happening was they just
got him to veto it well I'll I'll that
was the answer I I do want to get into
your prision but I want to address what
you just said about the the the myth of
the suicide and I'll use I'll use the
numbers that are widely accepted there's
something referred to as desistance
you're familiar with this concept not
really desistance is not detransition
detransition is if someone identifies
his transends underg goes what they like
to call gender affirming care and then
backtracks detransitioning desistence is
when a child
says that they're trans and and
experiences symptoms of gender dysphoria
but without any transition eventually
grows out of it typically this happens
around puberty the accepted rates are
between 65 and 95% of young of young
children who experience gender dysphoria
will grow out of it and they call this
desistance that means if we give the
most uh benefit of the doubt we could to
the gender ideology argument 65 around
65% of of children will desist okay
their argument however is it's
life-saving to transition these children
but suicide rates could be as high as
48% this means that you are increasing
the likelihood of suicide by by
transitioning a child if the if there is
a two to one chance the child will
desist do not transition them and then
give them a 50% chance of suicide well
yes it is a fact that suicide rates go
up after they transition I cover this
extensively on my podcast I've had D
transitioners on my podcast people that
have gone through with the procedure uh
you know got the bottom surgery as they
call it and then woke up one day and
realized their entire lives were AE and
to hear those stories I mean it's
incredible it's it's a true evil and it
is being backed by big Pharma uh there
is a lot of money obviously with these
procedures the drugs the puberty
blockers out there're putting them on
Loop BR um and it's a part of a larger
problem something that I'm obviously
very passionate about in terms of people
not being educated and being sold lies
and then going through a very radical
route of via big Pharma to to earn money
I I don't know how far you want to go
with this because um I I see a link to
transhumanism I see a link to Eugenics I
see the rise of autism also linked to a
lot of this as well there's a lot of
different components that we should
really talk about I and I think more
importantly especially when it comes to
the kind of chemical biological war
against human beings when you look at uh
male hormones and and women's hormones
they're being disregulated they are
being directly attacked fertility is
being directly attacked by a lot of
forces outside of us how can we address
a large larger what I see clearly a
depopulation agenda that has clearly
been put in play and being used against
us right right now so wrap it all
together I suppose as president what
could you do to address these issues
around gender ideology and even a
decline in fertility oh so those are I
think there's there's a couple couple
different issues I mean gender ideology
a lot of this is being foed through the
Department of Education right so the
Department of Education actually uses
the federal money as a news to get local
schools to adopt IDE IES that the
Department of Education decides are the
acceptable ones keep in mind the origin
of the Department of Education people
sometimes forget was to prevent Southern
schools in Southern States from
siphoning money away from predominantly
black school districts to white ones but
it's come somehow that institution has
taken on its purpose too these radical
gender and in some case racial
ideologies also onto local schools so as
it relates to the schools and the
ideology piece of it a lot of this is
the head of the snake the Department of
Education a lot of it violates existing
civil rights laws otherwise so enforcing
the laws on the books combined with
actually shutting down the Department of
Education is a pretty good start now as
it relates
to what I see as an appropriate place
for a federal you could talk about what
how Reagan did it using you could talk
about technically using how do we get
set the drinking age at 21 it was a 1984
law that effectively says you don't get
Highway funds unless you adopt this
particular set of laws that set the
drinking age of 21 but forgetting about
the legal mechanics and just as a matter
of policy what we want in this country
if you're not 18 years old you should
not be getting any chemical castration
or genital mutilation just as you can't
get a tattoo just as you can't have ad
an addictive drink of alcohol and so my
view is we do live in a free country if
you're an adult a fully grown adult
you're free to dress how you want you're
free how to identify how you want as
long as you're not harming anybody else
don't expect us to change the way we
compete in women's sports don't expect
to change the way we label our bathrooms
to change our language but if you want
to live your life the way you want as as
long as you're not hurting somebody else
with a presumptive expectation that the
rest of society bends to your delusion
you're free to do
so but kids aren't the same as adults
and so I think protecting children is a
policy position we've already well
accepted in this country and so the same
logic and the same mechanism we use to
prevent you from drinking by the age of
21 that we prevent you from getting a
tattoo by the age of 18 you should not
be undergoing genital mutilation or
chemical castration as a minor in this
country and I think there's a pretty
broad consensus around that and I want
to add to this I think it's interesting
because when it comes to the issue of
drinking you can have a drink at the age
of 21 and be fine you can have a drink
at the age of 31 and be fine alcoholism
that's bad but if at the age of 21 you
decide to undergo permanent and
irreversible surgery and that was a
mistake you can't come back from that
that's right so this is this is there is
a serious challenge in how we how we
deal with an issue like this because I
don't want people to take their lives I
think that's horrifying but we did have
a guest on this show who said that she
thought she was a man she believed the
gender ideology she was being a F on the
internet and she talked to I think she
said she talked to her brother and he
said get your hormones checked first you
likely have a hormone imbalance so
instead of adopting the gender ideology
and taking testosterone when she went to
the doctor and got her hormones checked
it turned out turns out that she did
have a hormone imbalance so they
prescribed her female hormones she said
almost instantly gender dysphoria
disappeared and she was in alignment
with her her own body yeah and so my
concern is if someone like that where to
undergo a surgery and then regret it
later I'm not going to pretend to know
what the a doctor can I just say one
word about this I don't know this person
or this individual but there is a really
small number of so I say there are two
genders and it's a clear clear point
there is a small number of people in the
general population who have chromosomal
abnormalities so we have you know what
23 pairs of
chromosomes two of them are sex
chromosomes x one is X and Y if you're a
man x and x if you're a woman but there
are some people who are born with XY y
or xxy and that's like a real thing
that's grounded in truth it's not made
up it's it it's in your genetics one is
called kleinfelter syndrome one is
called Jacob syndrome these are
exceedingly rare we're talking about one
in thousands at a much lower rate so in
those particular cases yes those are
instances of what you will call
intersects which is a different
phenomenon than trans but what's
happened is let's take those rare cases
to one side and I don't know if this
person you had here had such a thing or
not I would have said not not just go
check your hormones go actually get a
genetic test and actually understand are
you one of the rare people with one of
these chromosomal abnormalities it's
inborn but for the purpose of this
discussion in in our modern politics I
don't think that this pertains to public
policy take that off the table that
exists and we're going to acknowledge
that that's like a tiny tiny tiny
percent of the population it's always
existed it's a chromosomal abnormality
for the rest of people transgenderism M
the belief that you are your gender does
not match your biological sex that if
you're XX but you believe you're a man
it is mental health disorder and it
needs to be treated as a mental health
disorder through mental health care
which often isn't covered by Private
health insurance a lot of this is
through pharmaceutical intervention they
prefer pill pushing behaviors as an
alternative or people who run surgery
centers prefer surgery pedling surgery
as an alternative this is a mental
health condition and once we see it that
way we realize the compassionate thing
to do it's from a standpoint cuz I think
we gotten put into this box of see being
somehow antipathic because of adopting
this set of views that I think seems
like most of us
share I don't think the compassionate
thing to do for that kid is to affirm
that kid's confusion that's not
compassion that is
cruelty and I think we should actually
feel that shouldn't be just a thing we
say we should acknowledge that and act
with the compassion to say that kid's
going through a struggle help the kid
get through the struggle that's what we
should be doing not surgically operating
on them and chemically castrating them
you you pointed out that it is a mental
health disorder it is listed in the DSM
five as a mental health disorder this is
an academic statement this is not meant
to be invective yeah but there are many
people that I speak with who are liberal
or democrat that get offended when I
point out the fact that it is listed in
the dsm5 as a me mental health disorder
and my argument is uh there's another
mental health disorder called Pica are
you familiar with this no it's where
people eat things that aren't food we
don't affirm these things we try to help
these people because I agree with you as
you said to tell someone eating pennies
is something they should do is is
cruelty to them thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 P.M and become a member over at
timcast.net